hey guys Ryan right here and today I
want to be watching the trailer for
Hercules not that shitty one that came
out in January no no no no no this one
stars Dwayne the rock Johnson remember
that [ __ ] could you smell what The Rock
is cookin I remember what you sound like
I never watch wrestling anyway a lot of
people been telling me to check out this
trailer they say it looks pretty cool
I really liked Dwayne Johnson I thought
he was the best in painting game I
thought he did a really good job in GI
Joe retaliation I really liked him in
snatch even this guy makes like 18
movies a year and this is one of the 18
that's coming out this year so yeah here
we go let's watch this [ __ ] trailer
Paramount Pictures makes good movies I
don't see that line enough anymore some
creepy music
he can work buff oh dear
Spartans oh [ __ ] oh damn absolutely
scary
and great shot
Rock stop based on her
behind
now tell me
I am Hercules
nice oh cool oh you looked really look
really goal until that last part that
last part just look sleeper [ __ ] you
cheesy
yeah that film looks [ __ ] awesome it
looks way better than that shitty one
even I didn't see the shitty one that
one looks a lot better he effects look
great the way it shot looks really cool
I love the idea of all the mythological
creatures coming in there you know you
got a three-headed wolf and you got a
bunch of like dragon sea creature heads
Sinan yo lion kind of a weird one two
three I mean you should've shown the
line first and then the other ones that
would make more sense in terms of build
up but whatever yeah it looks really
sweet that part where he shattered oh
yeah I'm hard renée's you know the rock
used to do lines like that well you know
when he first started acting you know it
was his cheesiest [ __ ] when he said it
at that time I was like that's pretty
badass few people can pull that [ __ ] off
and make it sound really cool the rocks
gonna rock it
hey made a little pun there hey if you
guys are new to the channel subscribe
find it be too loud my landlord
threatened to kick me out last week
[ __ ] too much noise I'll show
you some noise [ __ ] I swear my landlord
give you one of the [ __ ] mythological
creatures in this gun day a movie [ __ ]
want Hercules to slice his head off I
hope my landlord never watches this
video but anyway yeah Kevin Sorbo
he's probably the best Hercules ever
easy replaceable and you know Z don't
worry Britain they should make a Xena
movie that would be so [ __ ] sweet and
they should get Lucy Lawless to be back
in it I think her name was lawless yeah
seriously Dwayne Johnson looks like
he'll be better than Kevin Sorbo [ __ ]
hate man landlord